- Good morning, everyone.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin
and the dean
of the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study at Harvard
University.
Welcome to our Annual
Science Symposium.
Let me begin with some things.
First of all, I'm
grateful to the speakers
who are here today and
participating in today's
symposium.
Thank you for taking the
time to be here with us.
Many thanks, also,
to Alyssa Goodman,
who conceived today's program
and will offer opening remarks
in just a few minutes.
I also want to express thanks
to Rebecca Wasserman, who
is the executive director of
our Academic Ventures Program
here at Radcliffe and also
to Jessica Viklund, who
is the Director of Events.
And I also thank the entire team
in Academic Ventures and Events
for organizing this very
exciting program, today.
I also want to acknowledge
members of the Radcliffe
Institute Leadership Society
and our dedicated annual donors.
It's because of you that
we're able to organize events
like this and open them
free, to the public.
Thank you.
I'm also delighted
to note that we
are joined by a
number of students
today, including more than
40 from Barnstable High
School, who are here with their
astronomy teacher Michael Gyra.
We'll get to hear from
a couple of-- yes.
[APPLAUSE]
That's right.
We'll be able to hear from
a couple of those students,
later, in today's program.
Today's symposium
will explore how
scientists across
a range of fields
tackle the undiscovered in
order to advance new knowledge.
We're getting a
behind-the-scenes look
at how science really works.
Generally speaking,
there's a chasm
between the way
scientists do their work,
and the way the rest of
us tend to imagine it.
Among non-scientists,
there's often the impression
that scientific
discovery results
from a linear process of
hypothesis formulation,
empirical observation,
and accumulation
of cold, hard facts.
That this view is so
commonplace isn't surprising.
It's called the scientific
method, and many of us
grew up learning it.
But the actual practice of
science is far different.
Hypothesis, formulation,
and empirical observation
are critical, to be sure.
But as we'll hear
today, unpredictability,
leaps of faith, the
element of chance,
and rigorous preparation for
the wholly unanticipated,
are equally important
to scientific discovery.
The work of scientists is
complex, dynamic, and creative,
not formulaic or rote.
Our first keynote
speaker, Stuart Firestein,
has compared scientific
work to searching
for a black cat in a dark
room, when very often there
is no cat.
Today's symposium
provides an opportunity
to explore what exactly
this means in practice,
and to consider the implications
for how we, as a society,
understand and value the
real work of science,
how we support scientific
discovery through research
funding and public
policy, and how
we prepare students to
become the pathbreaking
scientists of tomorrow.
I encourage you to learn
more about this last point
by visiting our student
poster session over lunch.
Today, also, is an
opportunity to take advantage
of Radcliffe's remarkable
interdisciplinarity
and engage in exploration
across academic and professional
boundaries.
I think it's safe to
assume that we each have
a more nuanced understanding
of our own disciplines
than do our colleagues
or peers in other fields.
The natural sciences
provide a particularly stark
illustration, as we will see.
But more generally,
we should never
hesitate to ask one
another to explain how
we go about our work and why.
We can learn a lot
from those answers.
Now, I'm pleased
to turn things over
to my colleague, Alyssa Goodman.
Alyssa is the
faculty co-director
of the science program at
the Radcliffe Institute,
a distinguished scholar
whose important work
spans several fields.
Alyssa also serves as
the Robert Wheeler Wilson
professor of applied astronomy,
and Harvard's faculty
of Arts and Sciences.
And now, Alyssa.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, thank you so much for
coming, and thank you, Tomiko,
and thank you so
much to Radcliffe
for making an event
like this possible.
I should say that I've been at
Harvard for a very long time.
And I've only been
affiliated officially
with Radcliffe for a few years.
And that started with the
Radcliffe Fellowship Program.
And some of you in the
audience have had the privilege
of being a Radcliffe Fellow.
And I'll just tell you
that if you enjoy today,
pretty much that's what being a
Radcliffe Fellow is, every day.
So it's really terrific.
So I think I have some
slides to show you,
to try to explain what
really is going on here,
today, because a lot of you may
be thinking, this looks cool,
but I don't know, what
is the undiscovered, what
is this symposium about?
I will fix this for you
with literally one word.
Are you ready?
Watch carefully.
OK?
Got that?
I don't know, and saying, I
don't know and I have no idea,
but I'm going to try
and act like a scientist
and figure it out, is actually
what the symposium is about.
And I should say that the
original idea was actually
to focus this, completely, on
education and communication,
and to change the
way that science
is perceived by the
public in the way
that it's taught in schools.
And we decided,
actually, in the end,
that the best way to do
that is to demonstrate
the way science
is actually done,
and to have a focus on
education in the poster session
that you've heard
about at lunch.
So we'll explain the details--
I'm sorry, not at
lunch yet, sorry,
it will happen at lunch--
and we'll explain the details
of that in just a minute.
But before I continue, I
thought I would give you
one small example
of a story that
just encapsulates the
undiscovered, in one
tiny vignette.
And it's actually a
story that has a lot
to do with my friend and
former colleague here,
Bob Kirshner, who
will give a lecture
in the undiscovered
series, which is described
in the back of your program.
So if you like what
you hear today,
there are many events
over the course
of the year-- some
of which have already
happened-- one of which
I'll mention in a minute.
But Bob Kirshner,
as many of you know,
is a very prominent
astronomer who
is involved in something
called dark energy.
And the discovery
of dark energy.
And what happened
was, a lot of you
know that the
universe is expanding.
And that's called Hubble's Law.
And the thought was that that
expansion should decelerate.
If you could measure
really, really accurately,
the galaxies moving away from
us and from every galaxy, what
the speed of that motion
is, exactly, that you
could find a deceleration.
So two teams, a team
that involved Bob here
at Harvard and another team
led by Saul Perlmutter,
went out to do this.
And they had a very carefully
designed experiment.
So as you just heard
Tomiko say, it's
not that what we're
talking about today
is total serendipitous luck.
We're talking about
when you have a plan,
but you don't usually find
exactly what you plan to find.
And in that particular
case, they went out
to measure the deceleration
of the universe,
and they found the
acceleration of the universe.
And Nobel prizes were
awarded, as a result. OK,
so that is a perfect
example of the undiscovered.
You do very careful work, and
occasionally you don't just
find something surprising,
you find the opposite
of what you set out to find.
And so this, to us, is what
gets us up in the morning,
not that we never think we're
going to find what we planned,
but the idea that
science is so exciting,
and that it's
undiscovered, that it's
the stuff that
isn't found out yet,
that is really interesting.
And I have another quote
that is actually my favorite.
And you say, why could Socrates,
Albert Einstein, and Barbra
Streisand be on the same slide?
And the answer is, if
you research this quote,
they've all said it.
So have many, many other
people, including me OK.
And so, if you think about
this, "The more I learn,
the less I know,"
what that means
is the more you become
expert about something,
the more you
realize that there's
a whole lot more to know, and
you don't know very much, OK.
And so the people who are
going to hear from today
are experts on a wide
variety of scientific fields,
and you'll hear them, hopefully,
be extremely honest with you
about what they do.
And so we've tried
to divide the program
into kind of three sections.
So we'll have a keynote in
the morning and another one
at the conclusion,
and then we'll
have a series of
other talks and panels
that focus, roughly,
on what we're
calling earth life and space.
But because of the
interdisciplinary nature
of the work being
discussed, they
couldn't even put everybody
in the right categories,
OK, so some of them kind
of bridge what's going on.
And so, to just give
you a little taste, when
it comes to Earth,
Nate Hultman will
talk about energy, and
environment, and policy,
and science, and a
mixture of those things,
and how the undiscovered
plays into that.
Stuart Firestein, who
you heard a minute ago,
will be our first speaker.
He will tell you about his
Ignorance Project, and he
himself works on neuroscience.
So I put him between Earth,
where we're ignorant,
and Life, which is neuroscience.
Jill Tarter, who will be
our last speaker today,
is probably well known to
many of you as the real person
upon whom the Jodie Foster
character in the movie Contact
is based.
And if you've seen that
movie or read that book,
you know that Jill
has dedicated her life
to a very systematic
search for radio signals
from extraterrestrial life.
Speaking of
extraterrestrial life,
let's go round in a circle.
When it comes to Space
and also Life in Space,
we have two experts with
us today, Laura Kriedberg
and Lisa Kaltenegger.
And they'll talk
to-- both of them--
about possibilities
for what we might
find on planets
around other stars,
in terms of the properties of
the planets and life there.
Joel Dudley, squarely
in the middle,
there, in terms of
Life, is actually
going to tell you about
what happens when you take
huge amounts of data
and look for things
that have to do with
life but don't always
find what you're looking for.
And I'll just leave it there.
And then Wally
Fulweiler is shown there
as bridging Earth's
and Life, because she's
going to talk about coastal
ecosystems and the effects
that we have on the
chemistry of those systems,
and then the effects that that
chemistry has back on life.
So hopefully you see
that this is kind
of a very interconnected web.
And I'm very pleased
that several people
are going to participate,
local people, as discussants.
And so the way that this will
work is people will give talks,
these discussants will have
time to ask their own questions,
and then you, the audience,
will be asked to participate.
So biographies for all of these
people and all of the speakers
are in the program
that you have here,
but I'm just going
to say that I'm
honored to have Conevery
Valencius from Boston College
here with us, for the Earth
session, Immaculata De
Vivo, who is my co-director
for science this year
here at the Radcliffe
Institute, for Life,
and David Charbonneau,
my colleague
in the astronomy
apartment, to tell us
about Space and
extrasolar planets.
So I just want to leave
you with one request.
This is an article that
was in the Harvard Gazette,
recently, about the ship, Tara.
Is anybody here--
were you lucky enough
to see Tara when
it was visiting?
Just raise your hand.
OK, so a bunch of the
fellows and a few of you--
so what Tara is, we
brought Tara here
because Tara was one of the
projects that actually inspired
this whole undiscovered theme,
that and Stuart's famous talk
that he's going to tell
you about in a moment.
So what did Tara do?
Tara Is a ship that's sponsored
by a French cosmetics company.
And one of the projects
they did recently
was to go around
the world and gene
sequence all of the
plankton that they
could find in the ocean.
And they took the number of
known species of plankton
from 15,000 to 150,000.
So if you think that what we
know about science is in books,
the whole goal today
is to encourage
what we maybe should call
"out of the book thinking."
OK, and we want to start
a conversation, both here
at Radcliffe, at Harvard, with
educators and with the public,
that science is not solved.
It's not boring.
It's not dry, and most
of it is undiscovered.
So that's what I
would like to say.
And then we're going to have
a very special invocation
of our event, and that's going
to come from Ceili Magnus, who
is one of the students from
Barnstable High School, which
Mike Garro was so
kind to bring here.
And he brought to
my attention a poem
that she wrote, inspired
by Stuart Firestein's work.
And we're going to have
her read her short poem,
and then we'll go on
to Stuart Firestein,
and hopefully you'll very
quickly see a connection.
So Ceili is an
amazing student who's
interested in both science and
the arts, which really embodies
the spirit of Radcliffe.
And I'm really pleased,
and I hope that we
can welcome her here, now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hello.
This poem that I wrote is
titled "Method Versus Muse."
"People have drawn a thick
line between art and science,
but what is science
without the arts?
The questions that need to be
asked can't come from a formula
when for centuries,
they've been deeply rooted
in the hearts of
geniuses and prophets,
with brains full of thought.
It seems that over
time, humanity
forgot how to think
critically and to question
with care, because in an
age of internet access,
the answers are
always right there.
And schools are so
focused on students
having all the right answers,
that they forget that we're
poets, designers, and dancers.
They drop facts on young minds
like piles of heavy bricks,
and expect us to
absorb information
stacked miles thick.
They teach us so much, but
now, we need to build from it.
They've marched with
us to base camp,
but our goals are at
the summit, applying
what we know to explore the
unforeseen, the undiscovered.
It's easier said than done
when curiosities like dormant
and smothered,
because every day I
see young minds afraid
to ask questions.
It cripples the scientific
world at its very foundation,
and research never comes without
curiosity, without a spark.
And my spark would
have died too,
but I found my
light in the dark.
My creativity led me to
ask all the right things,
and now I stand here before
you to ask, when will you
change the tune that you sing?
What will it take for
schools to open their eyes
to a world of unmatched
opportunity, that
very clearly lies in the
minds of young people
who still have their fire?
When will you take
their thoughts
and lift them up higher?
Maybe you will be
the one to inspire
someone's great questions,
or someone's desire.
Teach young minds to fall
in love with the unknown,
because for every question we
ask, there are many more to go.
Nurture the creativity we
all harbor in our hearts,
and maybe we'll give way for a
new way of thinking to start."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I can't thank
you enough, Ceili.
That pretty much sums
it up in three minutes.
And Stuart's got a
hard act to follow.
So as I mentioned
at the outset, we
have the biographies of our
incredibly impressive lineup
of participants today in
the program that you have.
And we're just going
to give you a couple
of little reminders of who
each person is as we go along.
And I'm sorry, but if we went
through all of their accolades
that would take the
whole time today.
So Stuart Firestein
is a professor
at Columbia University
who technically
teaches neuroscience there,
but he also teaches ignorance.
And today, he's going to
teach us about ignorance.
And just to say
a couple of words
about his scientific
research, he
studies the olfactory
system, the sense
of smell in vertebrate animals.
And he'll explain how he started
teaching about ignorance,
but I'll just tell you that
I love the title of his two
recent books, both titles.
One is called Ignorance,
How it Drives Science,
and the other one
is called Failure,
why Science is so Successful.
And so I'll just leave
it there and say, thank
you for coming,
Stuart, and we can't
wait to hear what you
have to say, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, this is quite a crowd.
Great thanks and appreciation
to the organizers
of the symposium,
to Dean Brown-Nagin,
even though she
stole my first three
slides, to Alyssa
Goodman, who stole
my second and fourth
slides, and to Ceili,
who stole my whole talk.
Nonetheless, I am
thrilled to be here today.
And it's nice to see such a
large group of people come out
for this, as well.
So let me preface this,
to some extent, by saying,
I don't think I'm
actually going to tell you
anything you don't, somehow
or another, already know.
I think the idea that science
is about ignorance and about
failure in so many
ways is something
that we almost all know,
in a kind of implicit way.
What I hope to do today
is to take those ideas
and make them
explicit, because I
found that by making
these things explicit,
we get to re-examine
them in ways that we
may have forgotten about,
and that new things show up
in that way.
So I'm going to talk about
ignorance, doubt, uncertainty,
and failure, which sounds
pretty existentially
bleak on a beautiful Friday
morning, but with the--
I hope-- aid of PowerPoint,
will turn these things
into more positive ideas.
So that's the notion here,
that science is successful.
And many other
things in our lives
are successful precisely
because of these things,
and that they're not typically--
or should not always be--
understood in a typically
pejorative manner.
So we might ask how successful
has science been, in fact?
This is a picture of
the Achuelean hand axe.
This was the first tools
made by human beings,
as far as we know.
This technology lasted for
some 1.2 million years.
All right, that's kind of a
long time for one technology.
But we could go a
little further forward.
Most historians or
historians of science
believe that the
Bronze Age is really
kind of the
beginning of science,
if you will, of the
beginning of some kind
of historical science, in
that bronze can't be taken out
of the ground.
It has to be smelted,
there's a process involved.
But the Bronze Age also
lasted for about 2000 years,
or some 50 generations.
So for 50 generations,
people just like you
and me, with the same
brain inside their head,
were born, grew up, and died in
precisely the same technology.
Now you know today, if you
take a two week vacation,
you're like two
operating systems
behind and hopelessly
out of date.
So clearly, things are
moving a little faster,
and that's primarily happened
since what we typically
call the Scientific Revolution,
about which there's some debate
and all that.
But I'm going to call it
the early 17th century,
beginning with people like
Bacon, Descartes, Galileo,
and so forth.
And now for the last 10 or so
generations, a mere 400 years,
we have these iconic
equations, just some of many.
But what's particularly
interesting
about these equations
is they not only
work here on the
earth, but they're
true throughout the
entire universe.
And that's a big step.
That's a big intellectual
leap forward.
We also know, of
course, that there
are huge advances in
technology, in transportation,
and communications, in
flight, and so forth.
My own particular
favorite, because I
was trained as a pharmacologist,
as in pharmaceuticals--
so for example, we
have this stuff here--
I don't know how well you'll
be able to see it from the back
there-- it was One Night
Cough Syrup, it's called.
It has in it alcohol, cannabis,
chloroform, and morphine.
Thus, I believe the name One
Night, where that comes from.
There is also Dr. Body's
asthma cigarettes,
for the treatment of
various bronchial disorders,
and so forth.
The big advance here, which--
I don't know if you can see at
the bottoms-- is that there's
a warning label here, actually.
These are not recommended
for children under 6.
So you can see that we've
moved forward in science.
Progress is the key to science.
How do we make this progress?
How does this all come about?
What's the actual method?
Well, Dean Brown-Nagin
has told you a little bit
about my idea about this.
This is an ancient
aphorism, synonymous,
and it says, "very
difficult to find
a black cat in a dark
room, especially when there
is no cat."
But I just find this
a very apt description
of what we do in science.
We fumble around in dark
rooms, we bump into things,
we feel around,
we imagine what it
might look like,
where things are,
where the cat might be hiding.
And whether we find
the cat or not,
we move into another black room.
So we find the cat, that's fine.
And then we just find
another dark room,
and if we don't find
the cat, well, we
move into another
dark room and look
for another black cat, which
is I think why scientists
tend to be so pale.
One idea, anyway.
But that's contrasted
with this notion
of the scientific method,
which we're all sort of taught
in school as how science works.
And I have a whole rant
about the scientific method
that I will try not to
get too deeply into,
but I think it's
a very wrong idea.
It's a wrong idea
because there's nothing
particularly
methodical or recipe
like about doing science.
I mean, really, it's more like
this, to be honest with you,
and kind of like that.
So let's compare the scientific
method, for a moment, to what I
think the process is more like.
So here's the scientific
method, you know.
You make an observation, come
up with a hypothesis about what
might be causing
that observation,
you do some test or
experiment you devise, make
a new observation, you
revise the hypothesis,
and so forth and so on,
in some iterative way.
The trouble with this idea
is that the key thing, which
is hypothesis, come
up with a hypothesis,
it tells you nothing
about how to do that.
Tells you nothing
about that process.
What do you?
Buy the book of hypotheses,
look a couple up?
Oh, this one looks
good, we'll try that.
So how do you come up
with this hypothesis?
So instead of a scientific
method, I'd say,
what we really
want to do is think
about a scientific process.
And that process
starts with ignorance,
something we don't know.
There's often some kind of
intuition about that thing.
We do observations,
experiments, they almost
invariably fail at a high rate.
So now we have a new question.
We make a question up.
We try some inspiration on this
question, some imagination.
Usually that fails,
so we revise.
We have an interim explanation.
That typically fails.
And eventually, we wind up
with yet a better question.
That's the scientific
process, and that's
where we end up with.
And I think this
is why we have made
the kind of progress we have.
So I want to try and prove
that to you, in a way.
This is a favorite slide
of mine, a favorite quote
of Marie Curie, who after
obtaining her second graduate
degree--
so she knew a lot
of stuff, right--
but still says, "One never
notices what has been done.
One can only see what
remains to be done."
And I thought it's
what that remains
to be done that's so lacking
in our education, our thinking
about science,
because that's really
what scientists think about.
When I go to a
scientific conference,
I sit through a long
day of boring talks,
and then I head for the bar
where I learn the real stuff.
And what I talk
about at the bar,
over a couple of beers
with my colleagues,
is not what they know.
Nobody cares about what we
know, but what we don't know.
What are the questions?
What remains to be done?
And I thought, well,
this is maybe something
important to think about.
Just in passing, I
have to note, again,
that this is one of my favorite
pictures of Professor Curie,
because I am convinced
that that glow behind her
is not a photographic effect.
I think that's actually
the real thing, you know.
In fact, today, her
papers, her notebooks
are so hot that they're
stored in a basement room
in the Bibliotheque
Nationale Francais, in Paris.
It's lead-lined, and
if you are a scholar
and want to go work
with her papers,
you have to wear radiation suit.
And I say this not just
as a joke, actually,
but because it's a
serious issue, here.
I think one of the ideas that's
often left out of science, just
as a side remark, is courage.
And I think this is a
real case of courage.
I mean, Marie Curie
knew what was going on,
and knew what that
was all about,
and what the dangers were.
And I think there's
a lot of science that
is dangerous in many ways,
whether it's intellectually
or physically, and it requires
a certain kind of courage
that we often discount
in its practice.
So, as was also
pointed out, I think,
by one of our introducers,
the thing about ignorance
is that it grows with knowledge,
that the more you know,
the more you know
you don't know.
And I like this, sort of--
this is not original with me,
several people have come up
with this kind of model--
if you think of knowledge
as that bright white circle
in the middle of this sea of
ignorance then, you know--
this is the only formula
in the talk, I promise--
but you know that
the circumference
of that circle, the
part of it that's
in touch with all
the vast ignorance,
is described this way.
And as that circle grows
as the amount of knowledge
grows, so does
that circumference,
by about six times
the radius also grows.
And so we increase our ignorance
as we increase our knowledge.
I think this is an important
process to think about.
We typically think that
we begin with ignorance
and we go to school, we read
a book, we do something,
and we gain some knowledge.
But then the crucial
question is, what do we
want to do with that knowledge?
I mean, it's useful,
knowledge is useful,
but what do we
want to do with it?
And I think the
thing we mostly want
to do with it is
make more ignorance,
but not just any ignorance.
We want to make
better ignorance.
We want to make higher quality
ignorance, if you will.
Because, you know, there's
low quality ignorance
and there's high
quality ignorance.
It's not all the same, right?
I mean, we argue about this.
This is what
scientists argue about.
Sometimes they're
just bull sessions,
and sometimes they're
grant proposals.
I'm just not clear
which they might be,
but nonetheless
it's what we argue
about, the quality of the
ignorance or, if you will,
the questions.
So the idea of
knowledge is to pose
a better question, a more
sophisticated question,
a deeper kind of question.
I'm going to use a
story here about I. I.
Rabi, a famous physicist who
won the Nobel Prize in 1944,
was it, for the development
of nuclear magnetic resonance,
a technique that's still
very important in chemistry
laboratories, especially
today, and gave rise
to the medical diagnostic tool,
magnetic resonance imaging.
And Rabi, who was a
professor at Columbia--
but I never knew him, he passed
away before I got there--
used to tell this
story, apparently,
that when he was growing up--
I think it's important
to say today,
that as a young immigrant
child on the Lower East
Side of New York, that
he and his friends
would come home from school and
their mothers would all say,
so what did you learn
in school today?
But Mrs. Rabi would
say, so, Isidore,
did you ask any good
questions, today?
Did you ask any good
questions, today, was
what Mrs. Rabi wanted to know.
And Izzy here won
the Nobel Prize.
I don't know what
happened to his friends,
I'm sure they did
OK, too, but I think
Mrs. Rabi had the right idea.
Yes, so one of the things that
happens when you write a book,
I learned-- and I've never
written a book before,
I write scientific papers
that nobody reads--
and then I wrote a book
that people did read.
And then they send you letters,
or in this case an email.
This is from a woman
named Kathleen Erickson
in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
I don't know Kathleen,
we've never actually talked,
but she read my book and wrote
me this interesting letter.
"One of my grade school
arithmetic teachers began
the first day of class
with a statement.
'I assume all of you learned
your multiplication tables
through 12.'
He waited while all of us
sat frozen, because we'd all
learned our tables through 10.
Terrified that he'd spin
around, point at me,
and say, quick, 7 times
12, I raised my hand
and admitted that I'd only
learned my tables through 10.
He then asked the
rest of the class
how many had
learned their tables
through 10, and of course
everybody raised their hands.
'All right, he said,
looking at the raised hands.
Kathy gets an A from me this
year because she's just learned
the one thing that is essential
to learn, when to say,
I don't know.'"
And Miss Erickson
says, "This lesson
remains the single
most useful experience
in my educational history."
So a word to the wise, from
Mrs. Rabi and Kathleen Erickson.
So when I say
ignorance, of course,
I don't mean just garden
variety ignorance.
I don't mean stupidity, or a
callow indifference to facts,
or things like that.
I mean something-- this is
a quote from James Clerk
Maxwell, possibly the greatest
physicist between Newton
and Einstein, who
said, Thoroughly"
conscious ignorance is the
prelude to every real advance
in science."
This notion of thoroughly
conscious ignorance,
not just, I don't
know, not just,
I wish I knew that, but rather
this thoroughly conscious
ignorance-- how do
you get to that?
Well, I found an
interesting phrase--
it was pointed out to me
by somebody in this search
for better ignorance--
the phrase is called
"negative capability,"
which at first sounds
like a bit of an odd idea.
This word was coined
by the dreamy eyed poet
John Keats, in fact, also in
a letter to his brother, where
he identified the word as
meaning "that is when a man--"
maybe we we should
say "person--"
"is capable of being in
uncertainties, mysteries,
and doubts without any irritable
reaching after fact and reason.
And it's this notion of
being patient with mystery,
with uncertainty, and doubt.
And Keats considered this
the ideal creative state
for the literary mind.
But I would say it's just
the ideal creative state
for any mind, that
when mystery, doubt,
and uncertainty
surrounds us, this is
when we become most creative.
This is when we think the
deepest and the hardest.
And to learn to be patient
with this, to develop
negative capability, I think,
is one of the critical things
that we would like to develop
in students, in ourselves.
This was sort of
said, similarly,
by a scientist in fact,
Erwin Schrodinger, who
I guess knows something about
cats, or doesn't, I guess,
as the case may be, right,
now that I think about it.
So Schrodinger said, "In an
honest search for knowledge,
you quite often have
to abide by ignorance
for an indefinite
period," again,
this notion of being
patient with ignorance.
All right, so I've taken you a
little bit through ignorance.
I hope you believe that the
unknown is very important.
But what about a deeper
kind of ignorance?
What about a really
deep kind of ignorance?
What about the unknown unknown?
What about the stuff we
don't know we don't know?
So kind of ignorance
squared, as it were, right?
This most recently,
unfortunately,
was said by this guy.
There are enough
people in the audience
who recognize this character.
For those lucky group of
you that are much younger,
this is Donald Rumsfeld who
was the Secretary of Defense
and the architect of our
misbegotten adventures
in Afghanistan and Iraq.
And he was called to
testify at the Senate
as to what had gone so wrong.
And he said, well there were a
lot of things we didn't know.
We knew that we
didn't know them,
but we tried to
deal with all that.
But what really got us were
these unknown unknowns,
the ones we don't
know we don't know.
And he was roundly
ridiculed for this,
but it's actually
a clever statement.
Unfortunately, he's not the
first person to have said it,
I learned.
And it actually appears,
to my knowledge,
earliest in a long epic poem
by D. H. Lawrence called
"New Heaven and Earth."
I don't actually care for the
poem, to tell you the truth.
It's kind of long, it
goes on, but in any case,
it's about the transition
from this life to the next,
if you will.
And towards the
end, there's a verse
that goes, "now here
was I, new awakened,
with my hand stretching
out--" into the unknown--
"and touching the
unknown, the real unknown,
the unknown unknown."
So how do we get to
this unknown unknown?
How do we get to this really
deep kind of ignorance?
And I would say one way--
maybe not the only way--
but one very successful way
is through failure.
You go to do an experiment
because you don't
know something, you think
you'll know something
at the end of the experiment.
Instead, the experiment
fails, it doesn't work.
So now you know that
there was something
you didn't know you
didn't know, before you
started the experiment.
Right, you understand?
I think I got that right.
And so what about this failure?
How can we use it?
This is a quote from
Benjamin Franklin, arguably
America's first
scientist, who says,
"Perhaps the history
of errors of mankind,
all things considered, is
more valuable and interesting
than that of their discoveries."
After all, the truth is uniform
and narrow, but screwing up,
I mean, there are just endless
ways of doing that, right?
And so it's far more
interesting, of course,
than just truth and success.
So there are a lot of
ideas about failure,
and I'd like to say none
of them are the ones I
want to talk about today.
I want to put them
up very quickly,
just so we get rid of them.
They're useful things if you
have someone on the phone who
has just had a terrible failure
in love, or sport, or business,
or something, and you
want to pep them up.
So here a couple of those.
"Success is learning
to fail again and again
with no lack of enthusiasm,"
often attributed to Winston
Churchill, who in
fact never said it.
But he gets lots of credits
for things he never said.
"Fail hard, fail fast," is a
favorite in the tech industry.
But this notion of, just get rid
of failure, just get rid of it
and get on with your success.
This was said by Thomas Edison
upon inventing the light bulb.
He claimed to have discovered
10,000 ways that didn't work.
I think he's exaggerating a bit.
Like, the light bulb going
off, oh, that's a good idea,
but he failed at that
like 10,000 times.
You know WD-40, the
lubricant that everybody uses
to fix everything, apparently?
The reason it's called
WD-40 is that there
were 39 earlier versions that
were no good, didn't work.
"Failure is an opportunity
to begin again more
intelligently."
Oh this, I actually
got in a fortune cookie
in a Chinese restaurant.
So I figured I'd
take a picture of it.
"Failure is an
opportunity in disguise."
And this is one of my favorites.
"If you're 40 years old
and never had a failure,
you've been deprived."
That was said by the
actress Gloria Swanson.
I'm not really sure
what she means there,
but it's interesting.
Nonetheless, I don't mean any
of these kinds of failures.
I don't mean the kind of failure
that just promotes resilience,
or from which you learn
something, from which you gain
some good personality trait,
eventually, or something
like that.
I'd rather take a somewhat
more enigmatic statement
from Gertrude Stein, the poet,
who said, "A real failure does
not need an excuse.
It is an end in itself."
So imagine values that are
just ends in themselves,
not because, oh, I didn't
think this through,
or oh, I'm sorry, I
a terrible mistake,
or this is a screw
up, or this or that.
No, this is just
an end in itself.
It's worth thinking
about that, I think.
Also, from the ever enigmatic
playwright Samuel Beckett,
"Ever tried.
Ever failed.
No matter.
Try again.
Fail again.
Fail better."
And this sounds so much like
the regular old failure trope,
I tried, I failed, tried again.
But then he says at
the end, "fail better."
How does one fail better?
So failures are an
end in themselves,
and the idea of failing
better are crucial things
to try and wrap
our minds around.
So what I'd like to say is that
failure is not only valuable
retrospectively,
because it eventually
lead to success or some
serendipitous discovery.
I mean, I think
those are all fine,
but they're not a requirement
for failure to be valuable.
Failure is an integral part
of the fabric, especially
in science.
It's integral to the process.
You can't leave it out or avoid
it, but you can utilize it
and you can improve it.
You can get better at it.
You can make it better.
So we could ask a couple
of reasonable questions
about failure.
One would be, how much failure?
I mean, probably
not 100%, but I do
believe we regularly
underestimate, significantly
underestimate, the
amount of failure
that would be acceptable.
So I use as, an example
from the natural world--
since I'm in the Earth
part of this thing,
or the Life part of
this thing anyway--
these guys are all the
top of the food chain,
they're evolution's
winners, as it were, right?
There are the kings,
or queens, if you
will, of their particular
niches, the air, the sea,
the land, et cetera.
And I'm sure you believe,
as I did for a long time,
that any time they
get a little hungry,
they just go out and
bag a snack, right?
But in fact, that's
not the case.
There's a vast
literature on this,
the predator prey literature.
And in the literature, you
will find that these guys here
are successful fewer, fewer
than 25% of their attempts.
75%, of the time, they fail.
That's why all those
prey animals are still
out there roaming around, right?
So apparently, with
a 75% failure rate,
you can still be the top of
the food chain, if you will.
Since we're at World Series--
is the World Series is going on?
There is one, right?
I'm from New York, I lost track.
I'm sorry.
So you know, our
two sisters cities
sport two of the
greatest hitters
of all time, in baseball sport,
two of the highest lifetime
batting averages.
But of course, they also both
failed about 65% of the time.
And as most of you
know, baseball today
will know that any hitter
who hits 300 or above
is likely to be sporting a $14
million plus yearly contract.
So with a 2/3 failure rate, you
can do pretty well, apparently.
So I think we, as I say,
significantly underestimate
the amount of failure
that's acceptable,
and that's important, because
this failure is valuable.
These failures are valuable.
And so we shouldn't--
we don't want to try
and exclude them.
And there's the obligatory
New Yorker cartoon.
But it is true that one
of the things that--
sorry, would be more fun, but
I don't think golf is fun,
anyway, frankly, I don't
think there's anything
you can do to golf
to make it more fun,
but it certainly would
be improved, yes--
so we do this regularly, and
the important thing here,
of course, is that failure--
in this, perhaps, slightly
counterintuitive way,
also gives us a
certain confidence
in the occasional success.
So if you fail quite a bit, or
failure is part of the process,
then you don't have an
infallible process, as it were.
You have a very fallible one.
And that gives us confidence
that when we do succeed,
we have actually made some
sort of an important step.
So failure and
struggle is actually
quite critical to the process.
Another question we could
ask is, how big a failure?
So I'd say let's go
for the moon here.
How about a debacle, right?
So a debacle is
currently defined
as an unmitigated
disaster, total failure.
But the word has an
interesting etymology.
It comes from a French word
that's not really in common use
anymore, dbcler, which
means to free to, to unbar,
or to unleash.
And its original meaning was in
a nautical term, ice breaking.
So the notion of
breaking up something
solid to provide new pathways.
Oh, that doesn't
sound so bad, does it?
That begins to
sound interesting.
And so we often think that
creativity, or innovation,
or things like this arise
from associating new ideas,
but I think, quite often, they
also, maybe more powerfully,
arise from
dissociating ideas that
have been too long associated,
which we no longer think
about having been associated but
which need to be broken apart.
The famous philosopher,
Spanish philosopher,
of the last century
Ortega y Gasset
said that it costs more
to dissociate ideas
than to associate them.
So I'd say, have a
breakthrough, right?
I mean, we still use this
word for a big discovery,
and yet it has the word
"break" in it, right?
And so I think this notion
of breaking things up a bit
is also very valuable.
So you can have a
fairly big failure,
and it can be quite useful.
All right, so I'm
going to leave you--
I'm not finished
yet-- but I'm going
to leave you with two key ideas
about ignorance and failure.
Negative capability,
this notion of remaining
in doubt and uncertainty but
having patience with mystery
and ignorance, and that
failure is an end in itself,
and one can learn to
fail better, as it were.
I think those are two key ideas,
and I see them as related.
So along with failure
and ignorance,
of course, comes
uncertainty and doubt.
And we've sort of mentioned
these a little bit,
so I just want to talk about
them for a quick moment, here.
To put pull aside the problem
of certainty and the value
of uncertainty-- because I think
we often reverse that idea,
and I'd say we're
wrong about that--
so uncertainty is something
that, in many areas
of our life, we like.
If you're playing poker
or you're at the casino,
or you want to watch the
baseball game tomorrow night,
you'd rather not
know the outcome
before you watch the game, where
it's kind of less interesting.
We have these spoiler alerts.
I'm guessing nobody
in this room,
probably, wants to know the
exact time of their death.
Who wants to know that, kind
of ruin the party, I think.
But these kinds
of uncertainties,
I would also say, have
a fundamental difference
with scientific uncertainty.
Because they will, I guarantee
you, they will all resolve.
The hand will be shown,
the ball will fall,
the game score will be posted.
And I'm sorry to say that
some digital place or another,
the exact time and date
of all of our deaths
will, indeed, be recorded.
I find this a, kind of a
grander uncertainty in science,
where there may be no ultimate
solution, no final resolution,
no guaranteed complete
answer, that this
is a kind of, if you
will, endless frontier,
that indeed the
purpose in science,
the purpose of science,
is not to get to 0 or 1
by doing more and
more experiments,
but to develop what I would
call stable probabilities,
a stable kind of
uncertainty that we can then
work with, and do work with,
in quite important ways.
So the question to me is
not how we become certain,
but how we get on so
successfully while accepting
uncertainty, which is
what science traffics in,
to a large extent.
And certainty, if we
reached it, would kind of
be the end of inquiry, which
doesn't sound very good to me.
Yes, so I included
this the last minute
because it's a favorite of
mine and I'm always looking
for some place to put it.
This is a haiku by the
famous Japanese haiku
artist Basho, "Too much
mist, can't see Fuji,
makes it more interesting."
Yes, often it does, because you
can think about where it is.
So I'm just going to make two
quick remarks about education,
here, because we're going
to talk about this later,
so I threw these in
at the last minute.
But I think one of the
things we mistake, then,
is we leave out that mist
in our educational process.
We develop these heroic
narratives about science.
My favorite is a sort of arc
of discovery in physics--
you go from Copernicus to
Kepler, Galileo, Newton,
Herschel, blah blah blah,
all the way to Einstein,
and kaboom, physics, there
it is, a very smooth arc,
and that's all there was to it.
But of course, this
wasn't the path,
this wasn't the way it happened.
Actually, there was
this rambling, confused,
often failed, wrong,
occasionally successful path
of discovery that might have
included these same people
but, you know, it wasn't
some nice straight arrow.
They went off cock-eyed
directions and things
like this.
There were long periods when,
kind of, nobody could figure
out what the next step was.
There are a lot of
forgotten names.
I should say a lot
of those forgotten
names are the names of women,
so Caroline Herschel, Marie le
Voicier, not just Marie
Curie, but her daughter Irene,
and Mileva Maric,
Einstein's wife,
and probably the better
mathematician of the two.
And so I think these
are the kinds of stories
that need to be told in
our classroom settings,
and in general to the public.
Oh, yeah, I know this
is a little weird,
but I thought I would give
you at least something useful
to take home with you, today.
So I'm going to conclude this,
here, how to hide a dead body.
So here's what you
do, just in case.
You have a dead body, you
go out to the local park--
you can go out to Cambridge
Green, here, if you want--
and you dig a nice hole
about eight feet deep,
and you throw the body
in the hole, of course.
Then you fill the hole up,
but you leave it, just dirt
and all the rest of that.
Now the police
come along and they
see this recently
disturbed patch of ground
that looks a bit like a grave.
Oh, let's go get
the cadaver dogs.
They get the cadaver
dogs and the cadaver dogs
go wild over it.
What they don't know is
that you, cleverly, have--
while filling this hole
up-- have buried a dead dog
at 4 feet.
So the police begin digging in
expectation of finding a body,
and indeed they do find the
body of a dead dog at 4 feet.
And off they go, right?
So the question,
though, is how long
will this body
remain undiscovered,
and how many of these bodies?
How many of these cadavers
are there, in science?
How many times do we,
in our laboratories,
do an experiment, get
the expected result,
say, oh, that's great,
and toodle right along,
not realizing there's yet
an undiscovered result
below that fabulous
discovery we just made?
So you could hide a
dead body this way,
but it's not a good idea
to do this in science.
What's the answer
to any of this?
I don't have an
answer any of it,
but I would like to
put in a pitch for what
I call pluralism in science.
So pluralism is an idea
in political theory
and in history and many other
areas developed, I think,
largely by Isaiah Berlin
in the last century,
a great philosopher at Oxford.
But I'd like to see
it applied to science.
And I don't think we
do a good job of that.
I'll use a quote
here from Niels Bohr.
I know I have a lot of
quotes in this talk,
but I don't do this for
the purpose of authority.
I just think people who said
something important shouldn't
be left out of the conversation
just because they're dead.
And I also think it's
important to recognize
that the conversation
has actually
been going on for a long time,
and it will continue to go on.
And our job is to jump
in, say something.
So Boris said, "The opposite
of a fact is a falsehood,
but the opposite
of a profound truth
is often another
profound truth."
That's a hard one to wrap
your head around as well,
but it happens quite regularly.
And we often don't let
this happen in science.
So Charles Pierce, a
Cambridge born philosopher,
a logician, mathematician, and
scientist of the late 19th,
early 20th century, considered
one of America's finest
in those areas--
although a little bit
of a strange character--
he said, science
is not like a chain
only as strong as the
proverbial weakest
link, that it is
not a chain of facts
where the weakest
fact, the chain breaks.
Rather, it's more
like a cable, made up
of many delicate strands,
each one quite fragile,
but when bundled together
of considerable strength,
and that the loss of any
one of these few strands
here and there will not
reduce, appreciably,
the strength of the cable.
And so the idea is to
keep the strands going on,
and not worry about
the few that--
or even the many--
that don't work.
So let me end this by telling
you the story of my dog.
This is my dog, in fact.
But that's not what the
story is about this.
This is a Newfoundland
named Orson,
out in his favorite environment,
the snow of Riverside Park.
But the story of my dog is
about young Tom, a seventh grade
student who's given an
assignment to write an essay.
Young Tom writes an
essay called, My Dog.
He hands it in.
Two days later, the teacher
comes back and says, but Tom,
your essay on My Dog is exactly
the same as your brother's.
Did you copy it?
And Tom says, no ma'am.
It's the same dog.
Yeah, so we all think
that's ridiculous, right?
But that's not what
we do in science.
We don't recognize that
there are a large number--
not an infinite number--
but many, many diverse ways
of describing the same dog.
And every one of
them has some value.
Some have more value,
some have less value,
but everyone has
some value, at least.
So let me just end with
these two last statements.
This is from Rita Dove,
one time a poet laureate,
"Failure is a favor
to the future."
And this is from the
poet E. E. Cummings,
"Always the beautiful
answer who asks
a more beautiful question."
And with that, let me ask
you what your questions are.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- So that was wonderful, and I'm
sure you have many questions.
And so let me just tell you
how we're going to do that.
You see that there's
a microphone here,
in the center aisle,
so please just
come to that microphone
to ask your question.
We'll be patient while
people make their way there.
And then, just as
you ask the question,
people love to talk, so
just try to be careful
and ask a question
pretty quickly.
And we'll take as many
as we can, so thank you.
- You know, the worst thing
is that I also love to talk,
so I'll try and make it
a brief answer, as well.
Yes.
- Could you comment on the fact
that so many of your references
were from the humanities,
an area we tend to think
is separate from science?
- Well I don't think
it is, obviously,
and I'm quite pleased to be
able to put so many references
to the humanities in there.
I claim that this is
a talk about science,
and I think it is--
and I talk about science
because science is what I know,
it's what I do--
but I don't believe
that it exists
isolated from the rest of our
culture in any way, shape,
or form.
And almost everything
I've said today
could just as easily be applied
to the arts, to the humanities,
to any of them, and that
many people in the humanities
have thought about these
questions very seriously.
I have a number
of friends-- see,
I'm going to go on too
long, but real quickly--
I have a number of friends who
are philosophers of science.
And one of the things they tend
to worry about is, do we care?
Do scientists care about what
philosophers of science think?
And I like to tell
them, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what we think
about philosophy of science.
I mean, it would be nice if
more of my science colleagues
thought philosophy of
science was important.
But I think science is one of
the most important things we
have in our culture.
We are a scientific culture.
If you think the
Renaissance was important,
or the Reformation
was important,
the scientific revolution has
had more effect on our lives
than either of those
things, really.
And so why shouldn't there
be a philosophy and a history
of science for the culture?
Not for scientists-- who cares
about them, really, you know?
So this is what I try and tell
my philosopher and historian
friends.
Do it for the culture,
don't worry about us.
- There's a paper
out on the internet--
which might have
been published--
- It sounds pretty dangerous.
- --in a reputable journal
that had a title, I paraphrase,
the majority of scientific
findings are false.
And it was a paper about,
I guess, statistics,
and it goes to the heart of,
have we failed or succeeded,
or how do we define
that, particularly
in fields where the evidence
is in the form of numbers?
And I'm just curious
where this issue of--
maybe people agree that the
supernova had this brightness,
but not on whether the
universe is accelerating.
Maybe they agree on this
pattern of epidemiological data,
but not on the
[INAUDIBLE] or approach.
- Right, so this
paper was about what's
come to be called the
replication crisis in science,
the inability of a
certain number of papers--
and we can argue
about whether it's
a large number or
a small number--
but a certain number
of papers that
are published in scientific
journals, legitimate,
which can then not be replicated
by another laboratory later on.
And this is considered
to be indicative
of poor statistical
power and a variety
of other sorts of things.
I gave a talk last weekend
on this whole issue,
so unless you want
to reset the clock
I can't give you the
whole answer to this.
Except to say that I don't
believe it's a crisis.
I believe that
replication failure
is a kind of scientific
failure that's very valuable.
I think when-- I'm not
talking about fraud, no,
fraud is another story, fraud
in science is the only thing I
believe the death penalty should
be used for because, really,
it won't work if people lie--
but I think many
laboratories publish--
all sorts of subtleties
in here-- but I
think laboratories will publish
the result that they generally
believe in it, they have gotten.
If it can't be replicated by
another laboratory, that often
means that there
was something they
did they didn't
even know they did.
It was one of those, we didn't
know what we didn't know.
And now we know that we have to
look a little deeper into this.
The original data is
probably reasonable evidence.
It just needs more evidence.
It needs a better
look, a deeper look.
Sometimes it will
turn out to be wrong.
But I have a phrase from
Charles Colson Gillespie,
a great historian
of science, who
said that in science,
revision is a victory.
And I think that should hang on
the wall of every laboratory.
So that's how we
get to these things.
- You indicated that ignorance
grows with knowledge.
Is there any
explanation as to why
ignorance, regardless
of knowledge or facts,
consistently remains in
the 38% and never changes?
- In the 38%?
I'm not sure what
you mean by that.
- In other words, ignorance
seems that it doesn't change,
even when there is new
fact, the new additions.
It still remains very
within that range.
It doesn't really--
- Yes, so again, I think this
is a different kind of ignorance
than the one that I'm trying
to talk about, which is
more of a communal ignorance.
It's not so much
personal ignorance,
people who prefer to disregard
facts or see facts only
in the particular way
that makes sense to them.
And I want to point out, I'm
not making a political statement
here.
I know it sounds
like one, but I'm not
making a political statement.
Or at least, I'm not making a
political statement that says,
this is more true of those
people on the right of center
than those people on
the left of center.
Marin County is full of
well-educated liberals who
believe they should not
vaccinate their children,
and they're out of their minds.
I mean, they're just as
ignorant as all the rest of it.
And so, you know,
nobody has nobody
has a hold on
ignorance in that way,
but that's a different
kind of ignorance,
I think, than the one
I'm talking about.
That's the low
quality ignorance.
And that, I'm afraid, we may
have to learn to live with.
Yeah, I don't know.
- So many of the quotations,
the wonderful quotations
you showed us today
are historical.
And you made, already,
the point that you
wanted to show that
it's a [INAUDIBLE],,
because I've been thinking
about that for a while, right?
So if that's the case, why--
I mean, this is not
a new realization--
so why do you think
it hasn't been taught?
It hasn't changed the
way to teach science,
given that, again, we have been
talking about that for a while.
And I just was
wondering, could it
be that a more
constrictive way to teach
it is actually more efficient,
or that you would figure out
that on your own, at
some point, maybe it's
a better way than
telling you that you're
going to fail many times?
- Yes, everybody
has big questions,
and there's this clock
ticking away over here.
Let me try to make a
quick answer to that,
and then I'd like to say that
I will be around all day,
so I'd be very happy
to have discussions,
especially at the
poster session, which
I intend to go to.
Because I think education
is, in many ways,
the key to this issue.
Let me just say that I
think educational reforms
and ideas for
educational reforms
have been around
for a long time.
Most of what I said today,
I think, is not new.
As I said, John Dewey,
in my opinion kind of
had this all figured
out 100 years ago.
To me, the question is, what's
the obstacle to doing this?
What's the obstacle to
making these changes
that we almost all see as
obvious, once you say them?
And I think the main obstacles
are evaluation and assessment.
We need to evaluate, we
need to assess students
and how they do,
ourselves, and how we do.
And the tools we use are
old, and decrepit, and blunt,
and not very good.
We need new tools for
evaluating and assessing
that include things like
ignorance, and failure,
and uncertainty, and
measurements of that,
and ways that students can
develop in those areas.
But we can still
evaluate and measure.
The only thing I will say
positive about all that
is that I think that's a
scientific problem that's
solvable.
I think with computer
science, with statistics,
with probability,
with game theory,
and even including
things like art auctions,
and economics, and
business evaluation,
we can learn to develop
new methods of evaluation
and assessment.
So this is a problem
that's solvable.
We just have to get to it.
Yes.
- Hi, there.
So my question, as a
lawyer, is when we're
developing public policy--
so what are the implications for
both the development of policy,
of uncertainty as
to scientific facts,
whether it's approving
medicines or coming
up with environmental
policy, in terms
of the substance of
those policies and also,
what should we be
embedding in our policies
to account for the possibility
that the initial facts
on which the policy is
based turn out to be wrong?
Do you see something
that we should
be doing to address that?
- You know, of course, if I
had a prescription for that,
I would have told
you during the talk.
And I don't have a prescription.
And I think what we
have to recognize
is that it's hard work,
that you do the best you can
with what you have, that
unsettled science, as I like
to say, is not unsound science.
It's simply unsettled.
And as we improve it,
we improve policy.
But you do what you
can with what you have.
And that's been
surprisingly successful,
so why not continue doing that?
There's a philosopher of
science here at Harvard
named Catherine Elgin,
who wrote a book called
True Enough, in which she talks
about felicitous falsehoods,
and that science is
never completely true.
It's never always correct,
it's just true enough,
is the important
judgment to make.
Longtime editor of
nature of a big science
journal, John Maddox-- he was
an editor for some 20 years--
was once asked by a
reporter, so how many
papers do you think Nature
publishes that turn out
to be wrong?
And Maddox answered like that.
He said, oh, that's
easy, all of them.
Because that's
the case, they all
should turn out to be
wrong at some point.
And so it's hard, I
understand, to make policy
on what you don't know
is absolutely certain.
But as I say,
science has learned
to work with uncertainty.
And I think politics can learn
to work with uncertainty as
well.
- I find your talk
very interesting
because you have a focus
on ignorance and failure
as fundamental to science.
And it was very
interesting to me,
because I disagree with that.
And for me, the most
important aspects of science
are curiosity and
discovery, and sometimes you
don't discover what
you thought you would,
but it's still very exciting.
And so I was
wondering, why do you
choose to focus on
ignorance and failure,
as opposed to curiosity?
- I would say curiosity
comes out of ignorance
and leads to failure,
most typically.
I don't want to leave
you, then, with the idea
that I don't think, for example,
that knowledge is important.
You need to know some things
in order to get anywhere.
As was pointed out,
I think earlier--
I think it was Alyssa who
said, you know, lawyers--
sorry, for the
lawyer-- but lawyers
don't make serendipitous
scientific discoveries.
Scientists do, and
biologists don't
make serendipitous
physics discoveries.
You have to be working on them.
You have to know something.
So oddly enough,
the higher the level
of expertise, in my
opinion, the higher
the level of ignorance
and failure, in fact.
It's the experts
who fail the most
and recognize how
to fail the best.
I don't want to
dismiss curiosity.
I'm really trying to kind
of re-balance the thing,
because so much of what
we think about science
seems to be based on facts,
big textbooks full of facts,
potted histories of discoveries,
and the idea that we
don't fail, that we just go from
great success to great success.
And just to balance
that, I'd like
to simply suggest that
if you want curiosity,
curiosity does not, in
my opinion, come out
of textbooks and
arcs of discovery,
genius-made
discoveries, as it were.
But curiosity,
imagination, intuition,
inspiration, this
comes out of, I
think, a willingness to
be ignorant, if you will,
and a willingness to fail.
I think we're talking
about the same thing.
- Stuart, that was fantastic.
So as a scientist,
I've had my many years
of ignorance and failure.
So I had a more
general question.
So for young researchers
coming up in the field,
they're not allowed to admit to
ignorance and failure because
of the pressures
of universities,
and tenure, and academic
success, is what is valued.
So as a seasoned
researcher as yourself--
and I say that in the best way--
[LAUGHTER]
- Thank you for
making that clear.
- How do we instill
this idea that you
can fail, and be ignorant, and
still get tenure at Columbia?
- Well, I did.
Yes, it's an important question.
I think this is--
I really didn't have
the time to develop it,
but I think it
could be developed,
and I think there are lot
of people working on this--
I think this is where
ideas of pluralism
become so important,
that there are so
many ways to contribute that--
and again, it's kind of an
assessment and evaluation
problem.
So I don't think pluralism is
actually a very useful thing
at the bench, if you will.
I mean, if I'm in the
middle of an experiment,
I don't want to be thinking
of 20 other possible ways
that this experiment
could be done.
I need to be dedicated and
focused on that experiment.
But in so much else that we
do as scientists to support
the scientific structure
such as promotion
and hiring, curriculum,
or reviewing papers,
reviewing grants, all
of these other things,
I think a more serious approach
to pluralism in those areas
would benefit the whole
structure, and all the people
in it, tremendously.
Because they would
allow for things
like ignorance and failure.
If you have really
good ignorance,
if your questions are good, then
I want you in my department.
I don't care if you
know the answers.
I just want you in my department
if your questions are good.
And the better your
questions, the more likely
you are to fail.
But you're likely to
fail in creative ways.
And some of those failures
will be really useful to me,
as well.
But I appreciate it.
It's a very difficult
problem because we
have students who we want
to promote along the way,
and all the rest of that.
But somewhere along
the line, they're
going to have to learn
that it's mostly failure
and an awful lot of ignorance.
Thank you very much, thank
you all very much, yes.
[APPLAUSE]